hey there dave here welcome back to the
44th ever
episode of the iced coffee hour i'm dave
with my two good uh friends here
we have graham we have jack and we're
ready to talk about iced coffee
but how much is the podcast made you
you funny you should ask it's made forty
eight thousand
three hundred and seventy nine dollars
and forty six cents
wow wow that was good matteo you gotta
tell us
what that breaks down to that's amazing
thank you so much dave
yeah well dave thank you so much for
coming out here absolutely
i'm i love coming to la i don't get to
do it that often so
uh th this is the first time i've been
on an airplane in a year
how was it it was actually i'm fully
vaccinated now so uh
wow that's that's why i'm that's why i'm
here that's incredible
um but still everyone everyone wearing
their masks i i
absolutely would be freaked out on a
plane even with masks
without the vaccination so i was super
happy to be vaccinated but
everything was fine people were wearing
masks everyone was well maintained and
yeah we flew to utah to meet with the
strad man
and that was our first time flying and
probably the same about a year and a
half
and we were surprised i mean they were
so stringent on
everything i think they were taking
taking temperatures as you were like
going through like certain things
i felt safe like i felt probably more
safe on an airplane
than i would like going out to a
restaurant really yeah i felt nervous
it was just because yeah because you're
gonna crammed in a small space wouldn't
i think that you're you're crammed in a
small space but i think getting
onto the plane is the riskiest part
because actually on the plane
they have like good air circulation they
they turn the air over inside the plane
way more frequently than a restaurant
yes
i think there's way more liability if if
an airline messes up they got a lot
writing if
a restaurant messes up it's like you
can't really prove it's the restaurant
you know i don't know anyway if you have
300 passengers on a plane all get
covered you know yeah
well anyway thank you so much for coming
on today could you tell us a little bit
about yourself for people who aren't
familiar with you
i love the dumb money live you you know
us from dumb money live
right you may know me from dum money
live that's just uh
basically we started that when we went
into lockdown
and we started putting our video
conference calls that we were just
having amongst my two friends chris and
jordan
talking about stocks what are we doing
in the market and it kind of turned into
a show
but before that we had an original dumb
money channel that was all about our
startup investing which we
again we just decided to start taking
cameras with us
to meetings business meetings that most
people would
you know never see but we kind of
thought of it as the anti-shark tank
where
basically we were we're entrepreneurs
we're trying to find the next big
startup investment
and it was hopefully kind of an
interesting vlog style format to uh do
that
give us some click bait here we got to
click bait the title how much money are
you investing with
give us some stats that we could just
hit him in the beginning
i can tell you that 25 million dollars
is where is that where we are now we're
more than that okay
but at the end of the year we had turned
around 10 million into 25 million
so that's that's kind of what what we're
investing with we're investing our own
money we're not a fund we have nothing
to sell
we had a really hard time with youtube
because we didn't have ads running at
all
and so nobody was able to even find our
channel at first and so as soon as we
turned the ads on
people started finding the channel yeah
just you know took
took a little uh growing pains to learn
that what do you mean by we
are investing with 25 million dollars
it's me and my two buddies
and we have kind of just done this our
whole lives we well not our whole lives
but
once we sold a software company we had
some money and
instead of going to work for another
company we
started to start investing in other
startups all right so we got to go way
back tell us from the beginning
how do you start a start where a
software company sell it then turn 10
million into 25. we got so many
questions here
there's so there's too many pieces to
the puzzle that are missing right now
you just have to subscribe to the
channel that's all you really need to
know that's
so i don't know there's not a it's not
an easy one two three started like
process
age ten so when i started age ten when i
was ten years old i wanted to be a radio
dj
okay and so that's where my kind of
fascination with media and that's the
whole reason we're on youtube now is
i just thought now that i'm kind of
retired and working for myself
why not have some fun with it and make
videos
um but that's i i don't do it for a job
it's just
something fun to do sure um
so when i was 10 i wanted to be a dj and
that made me want to eventually go to
film school i went to film school
never actually got to use that in my
professional career at all i went to
um so i went to nyu graduated lived in
la for a year
okay um thought i was going to be in the
entertainment industry
decided that wasn't for me so then i
went into uh
basically radio production out of my
bedroom
and i was doing voiceovers and
production for stations all over the
country
i sold that company when i was probably
oh god what was that 20 years old and uh
22-ish i went to work for a little
little startup company called
broadcast.com right after
yahoo had acquired it from mark cuban
for four billion dollars it was a huge
huge thing that put mark cuban uh on the
map
right uh and so from that point
i was working a corporate job at a big
startup company and that was really my
business school education
film school didn't prepare me for the
business world but working at yahoo
during the heyday of
you know before before google was a
thing yahoo was
the you know the home page of the
internet so before that it was aol
remember that aim yeah we'd say that you
could do the voiceover then
well how do you've got mail
oh if that doesn't make you want to hit
the like button i don't know what will
two good questions how much did you sell
that voiceover company for
22. that was that was not like a
life-changing amount of money
it was uh it was not much but it was
enough
so that i could move out of my parents
back house which is where i was living
at the time i put foam all up in the
closet and i was doing that out of their
back house why would they want to buy it
did they grow it yeah so we were doing
um
production for radio stations 40 40 or
so stations all around the world
i was the voice over uh for power 100 fm
and istanbul turkey
because they liked american sounding
voices and
i was cheap i was running ads in the
back of radio and records magazine
wow which is like a print publication
and uh yeah i was trying to give us an
example
of like what you would say like welcome
back to power 106 where hip hop lives
well so in dj voice or in in like
announcer voice
like how you would do it like like 4x96
is
serving up hits that's the that's the
friendly voice and then you have the uh
uh z 100 fm
that kind of voice and then you have
focus that is so good
don't do uh you're putting me on the
spot so uh
the best mix of the 80s 90s and today
the new mix 102.9 i'm dave hanson we got
another
all request and dedication hour coming
right up you know you can start puking
like that
cool yeah so jack you got to
i need a script i can't just freestyle
it that's that's the hard part
um i yeah hey graham i'm calling in to
make a request
welcome to 97.1 i don't know i can't do
it
welcome to smooth jazz oh my god
87 points i i actually got to
be a smooth jazz dj for one night when
uh we were again i was 18 years old i
was in high school
and uh the the program director for the
radio station that i was working in
was moving over to turn this smooth gas
station into a top 40 station
and the last night before we pulled the
plug on smooth jazz they put me on the
air from like
you know 8 p.m until midnight and i got
to
you know switch the station over into
being a top 40 but i got to do smooth
jazz for a night that's really nice
i didn't know any of the music i was
playing it was great you should have
done the intro in that voice
welcome back to the 44 back to the 44th
ever annual
it's amazing i need a script too that is
cool all right so yeah
so how did you get a job like a
corporate job with a film degree
well it was a production kind of
company it was broadcast.com which was
streaming
audio stuff onto the internet and later
video and uh
i started um what was my first job there
was
i was like a producer who was uh helping
coordinate
production like just getting getting
satellite feeds in and
putting them into an encoder and sending
it out on the internet and
over the course of 10 years in that
corporate job that was my education
and i basically did 10 different jobs i
was a website manager i was a director
of
marketing i ended up in the marketing
department and
that you know we did so many cool
projects that yahoo never really got
credit for
things like crash the super bowl that
doritos
super bowl promo that for years they
would they would let people submit their
commercials and then if you would get
chosen that was originally a yahoo
promotion that my team
did so interesting
so then what evolved after that that got
you into investing large sums of money
yeah so all during that time i was
fascinated with investing and i was
investing
the small sums of money that i had and
learning and that was
probably you know the the reason that i
feel confident
in investing now is because i've made so
many mistakes when i was younger
so i was i was doing just crazy yolo
option trades before yolo was even a
thing
like because instead of having the
capital to actually
buy shares of a company i would be like
oh well i can
control 100 shares at a time if i buy
these out of the money
options knowing that i'll probably lose
all of my
investment but is kind of gambling meets
um
investing but what year was this but
first we have to talk about one of my
favorite services out there let me guess
privacy.com you betcha i love
privacy.com i just love it so much
it's just so good i know man me too and
trust me you guys will feel the same
once you start using it too privacy.com
is an amazing service that protects your
credit cards when you're buying things
online so say goodbye to fraudulent
charges canceling subscriptions and all
of the worries that comes with buying
things online here's how it works
instead of handing out my credit card to
everyone i can link my credit card to
one of privacy's virtual cards
and then i can pay for things using
their card instead of my own and that's
not even the best part these privacy
cards have
massive perks such as being able to
pause the card instantly set
transaction limits and cancel with the
click of a button this protects you from
ever having to worry about your card
ending up in the wrong hands
plus if you go with the privacy pro plan
you'll actually get one percent cash
back
and this is outside of any of the
rewards you receive from your real card
oh my gosh one percent cash back people
are actually making money with this plan
the cash back is super nice
so do yourself a favor and protect
yourself when you're buying things
online with privacy.com there are so
many perks i literally can't cover them
all you will also receive five dollars
by clicking the link below or heading to
privacy.com
ich you really don't want to miss out
that is privacy.com
ich thank you so much privacy and back
to the podcast
that was well all through college so
that was in the
late 90s okay um
how much were trades back then it was
ridiculous
so back before so i i got in on
you know using online i used e-trade
that was my first
online brokerage but i had an
old-fashioned broker who was a human
being who you would call up and have to
make a trade and i think it was like 50
every time wow you wanted to buy or sell
a share
and so and options were even more so
once e-trade came around with their
i was at 30 at the time or something
that seemed like oh my god i can do
30 trades now and then they got cut in
half and 15.
now i remember i used scottrade back in
the day and i think that was
i think it was between seven and twelve
dollars
per trade either way so it didn't matter
how much you wanted to buy either it's
like if you wanted to buy one share for
15
well that's going to cost you 12. that
is a lot to make up yeah
so and that's and that's another reason
that options kind of helped with that
because
you had a better chance of being able to
pay the commission
on this thing that would have i mean it
was it was not a great
investment strategy but i want to hear
about your options trading and how
that's going because uh
some of the earlier episodes of this
option i love
to talk about options i love you know
what jack would have been made more
money though had he just
bought the actual stock instead of the
option i wouldn't buy
instead of selling call options you were
writing call options on uncovered no
covered calls
i was still totally like making money
but i was mostly making it just due to
like selling out of the money call
options yeah so i was making money on
the appreciation and then i would end up
losing money
most of the time on like the actual
options contract
yeah that was after my first 20 out of
20 profitable options trades
those were 12 true options yeah they
were they were very very conservative
but uh yeah that's but that's what you
need to do to learn
and get into it i i love you doing it
and that's kind of why we
do dumb money is to just get out there
and let
people start thinking about investing
and start thinking about things that
they may have never thought about
i think that the whole idea that robin
hood lets you invest
for nothing and it makes it easy in a
game
i love that yeah i actually kind of
agree with you i think so long as people
are investing even if they're making
mistakes
losing even like a few thousand dollars
at least they're out here
doing it you know well just know your
risk tolerance know what you're willing
to lose
and you should be okay with it if you
know that i'm i
have set this money aside this is not
what i need to pay my rent this is not
what i need to pay for my life expenses
this is just extra money
go for it there's not much of a
difference though between robin hood
right now in a casino
i'm all for the gamification of it i
love
being able to get a free stock and you
go and see the confetti and you
go and swipe up to buy a stock and it
just like people are clapping for it's
fantastic
i love it but there there's not much of
a difference between that
and putting your money on disagree i
disagree most of my friends that use
robin hood don't do these crazy like
short-term out-of-the-money call options
they just buy like common stock like
they just buy equity it's
that's how i see a lot of my friends do
it and i know a lot of people use it as
a casino but i wouldn't say that it's
like
comparable and i think you know you can
do both you can actually go to a casino
and be very conservative in your
gambling right
you know the odds you can play a game
that you have that 51
there's a there's a smart way to do
anything and then there's the gambling
way to do it and i think you can use
robin hood for either and
i think that it's fine if you want to
have fun sometimes and just make some
crazy
i i bought gamestop i did and i knew
that i was either going to
it was going to be a huge winner for me
or i would just cut my losses at about
you know half and yeah what did you buy
gamestop
at i have no idea when i bought it in
the first the first wave of uh game
stops insanity
um it must have been like 50 bucks 60
dollars around there okay
i do so many things like numbers don't
mean anything to it okay but basically i
know that i
lost about half of what i invested wow
okay that was what i was
this is my risk capital that i was you
know not needing the money
and for me it was i don't really
remember but it was probably around a
hundred thousand dollars
and that was just that was the gamble so
you bought my shares that i sold
and you're comfortable losing a hundred
thousand dollars
yeah how i i i feel like even for me
it's like
locking in a loss of 100 grand i
immediately think like all the things i
could have done with that
but are you also thinking of all the
things that you can do with the money
that you haven't sold and all of your
crazy stocks that have appreciated that
you're
not willing to sell because of uh tax
implications
no but i feel like losses for me are so
much harder than the game like like the
gain i know it's kind of like all right
it's there
i could use it if i need to but a loss
especially a realized loss
so that to me is like all right that
money's gone it's definitely not coming
back
and i could have bought all these other
things instead
yeah i could have bought some really
nice vacations that's the one thing that
it really gets me because i i'm a little
bit cheap when it comes to
actually spending money on things but i
am less cheap when it comes to
like the opportunity of making money on
something
so yeah that would be a really nice 50
000
vacation if you think if you think of it
that way but i think of it as a loss
that i get to now not have to pay taxes
on some of the money that i made in
another stock
so it's a 50 000 yeah loss okay
you're great at separating emotions and
investing that's a total skill
a total skill yeah and so probably the
thing
that i learned when i was young was
that buying the dip is a thing i would
just get freaked out it's going down
it's never coming back i can't afford it
this is too much i was maybe on margin
and forced to sell or just like had
paper hands
and had to had to lose out on on stocks
that had i
had i just held on for another you know
year
even it would have totally turned around
i lived through the the dot-com bubble
right
i was working at yahoo when the stock
they gave me all this it was 1999 when i
started working there that was the year
they were added to the s p 500.
and they gave me stock options on the
day that i started
and that was a day that they were added
to the s p so that was a all-time high
for them
and they kept going up they kept going
up within you know
a couple months i was a paper
millionaire and i never
made more than like fifty thousand
dollars a year at that point in my life
and so that was just insane but i
couldn't sell it and uh
within the time of the vesting of those
options
uh i was underwater in those options
pretty much for the entire 10 years that
i was there
they kept giving me more and more so it
it worked out
what's the lock up here is it a year it
was one year of vesting for the initial
i think it was a four year vesting but
for the initial hit it was a full year
before then they started investing
monthly quarterly or something
yeah so were you able to sell after that
year yeah but
all those were worthless they were
underwater so i had i had to wait for
them to give me more options the next
year
so it's just call options that they buy
like on your behalf basically they're
basically
a bonus or something yeah and then they
expired worthless
expired and they were actually 10-year
call options and they
expired worthless 10 years later that's
how bad the dot-com bugger was yeah i
have no idea yeah that's
that sounds like.com bubble was terrible
for some of the stocks cisco was a big
one
cisco was one of the biggest runners uh
during the dot-com bubble and even
today like 20 years later it still has
not recovered to the same price it was
back in 2000.
i found an old login on my yahoo where
you tracked your portfolio at the time
and like
half the stocks on there were completely
out of business like
zero is quote even available including
yahoo's ticker because they were
required so many times
uh and then the others like if i had
stayed and so i can't remember which
which ones but if i had stayed in some
like tried and true
companies amazon was one of the stocks
that i held back then that
you know it it was going down down down
and i lost money and am
how do you lose money in amazon in the
90s
like i must be the worst investor ever
but it's it's
you know you sell without uh
waiting are you worried about another
bubble today
where do you see the warning signs
flashing i
wish i had that crystal ball i i i'm
worried about it but i'm not
proactively uh in fear about it
so when we had the big crash
in march last march yes we're already in
march again
yeah i know did this crash correspond
with the last crash
almost no no no no wonder if it's like
bitcoin yeah it's gonna be like it's
exactly
it's an ankle thing
very close actually i think the bottom
was march 23rd
so we'll see march 11th right i don't
know i don't know the exact top
but no no it was late february i think
was the time was it and then it slowly
started going down
i was on vacation at the time and lost a
million dollars
wow because i was not paying attention
and
uh that is a huge lesson but i was able
to aggressively get in there and
um i basically was shorting
the spy and also just shorting it and
also buying puts on it yeah
and i was able to not only get back to
break even but i i doubled my net worth
in the past year wow
so you were buying puts in as it was as
it was falling apart
i was a week late so i made a video on
my uh my
first channel hey there dave here all
about how i
paused the stock market as it was in
free fall i watched that video
i watched that video back then i'm gonna
check that video out right after you
would like it
because it does talk about how i used
options too that's amazing
explain how that works for everybody who
is not going to watch that video
but first we have to thank our sponsor
surfsharkvpn
have you ever been searching how to make
your own 20 cent iced coffee only to get
starbucks ads for the next few days well
that is because advertisers and people
are constantly stealing information
online
surfsharkvpn protects your information
when you're browsing online and lets you
surf the web
risk free with surfsharkvpn you can
connect to your
own private network to access the
internet instead of using public
networks where your data is at risk
you can also use surfshark to watch your
favorite netflix shows that aren't
available in your country
since the office isn't available in the
united states i can actually connect to
a vpn in canada and then watch it with
surfshark
and the best part is you can actually
try surf shark risk free because they
have a 30-day
money-back guarantee and when you use
the code iced coffee you'll get an
83 discount and three extra months for
free
visit surfshark.deals iced coffee and
enter promo code iced coffee for an
83 discount and three extra months for
free
and as always the link is down below in
the description so thank you so much
surf shark for sponsoring this episode
and back to the podcast
everybody's gonna just watch it we'll
just link to it up here it's cool easy
no um
basically when the stock
okay when stock prices are going down if
you want to
not let and you own that stock and
essentially i'm i'm
saying the s p because my portfolio was
a pretty good representation of the s p
i had
you know amazon and apple and microsoft
and you know all of
those tech companies that were going
down at the same rate as the s
p um that's kind of what my portfolio
was doing so i used the s p
as a proxy for that and essentially
as the market was going down i was
buying puts
so that that basically gives me the
right but
not the obligation to buy
you're forcing someone else to buy the
shares away from you yes
when you sell when you buy and you buy a
put you're forcing someone else to buy
the shares and so
it's a hedge yeah if you have to exactly
and and but i
but i was basically it was a covered
hedge because my portfolio was backing
it up so i knew
that worst case i'd break even and and
sit on the sidelines during a recovery
but best case it keeps going down and
i'm going to profit on it continuing to
go down
so smart i just so i love that that's so
cool
so wait so you how much did you make
during all of that was you said a
million dollars
well i lost you but you made a million
but i hadn't actually sold anything so i
didn't actually
take any losses so um i i
was able to before the market even
started correcting i
made a million dollars back so that was
an actual made million once the market
did correct
uh in all it was probably a million and
a half in
in a month and a half period wow
that's incredible but then last week i
mean over the last
i don't know when this is going to air
but remember when the market was going
down so bad for like five days in a row
that's a million dollars right it's it's
it's easy it
easy come easy go but you just have to
kind of be prepared now is that in the
25 million
portfolio no that is just in my portion
of that which is about 10. okay
and you know together it's it's probably
we're
we don't all disclose every dollar so i
i say that my
my main investing portfolio is about 10
million
chris is i think is 25 and jordan
doesn't disclose his so
we're at about 35 of this does jordan
not disclose his because
it's the lowest or because it's the most
it's got to be one or the other that
can't tell you either one on that but
uh i think it's the moment jordan did
well because he was uh one of the
co-founders of the software company that
we sold and i
i came here chris and i came in a little
late on that
not as co-founders but his founding
partners okay
it's the most
i think i would be too i think as as
i've grown my portfolio the less risk i
want to take i'm okay taking like
thrown 10 grand here and there that i
think my 10 would be the equivalent
of your 100 where if i were to lose 10
and lock in a loss
it is what it is so i think maybe you
just have a higher threshold but
yeah but i also have a higher demand you
know i want to make more money
like that's that's my drive yes to to
get to the point
basically i got to the point where i
knew i would not have to work
when i hit i think two million dollars
and from there i was like okay what do i
want to do with my life
what what can i do i just want i want to
travel i want to have fun i just want to
i enjoy the market i enjoy making videos
i what do i like
and so that's kind of what i have
focused is that the point where you
decided you're going to do the financial
independence route when you hit two
i mean i never really thought of it as
you know following someone's
system but yeah when i when i had two
million dollars in cash or
in equities i was like yeah that's good
i
know that worst case scenario i can
stretch this out
and survive the crazy i'm still just
like the same level of
worried oh it doesn't matter how much
money i have i feel exactly the same in
terms of like
i'm worried like something's gonna
happen i'm not gonna have enough money
to pay for it
all the time still well i mean what are
you invested in now are you
are you fully invested in equities no uh
i think eight well if we're are we
talking gross i think like eight and a
half
uh real estate four and a half
four six stocks uh two something cash
and then i don't know 600 grand and just
like random
yeah 700 and random but 304 gt
oh yeah four gt yeah and a 4g team
that's
a good investment that's i would
kind of like that appreciating asset if
someone offered me
uh how much 350.
no it's not worth it to sell for 350
four i would sell it at four yeah
i feel like that's
i would get a golf i would get the golf
version of the 4g i'd spend 450 and get
a golf so i've come out 50 grand of my
own
money by the gulf well i'm gonna have to
go out to vegas and see that
vehicle so you could buy it you could
buy it no
no i'm not a car person to me that's
that's just not that's never been my
thing
i literally have every car that i bought
it was like
they gave me this is a loaner at the
dealership and i'm like yeah that's
pretty good i'll buy that next time
like my i have a range rover velar now
and i had that because it was like
those are nice those are pretty deluxe
great
they're not as bad as you would think so
that's a four cylinder right
you're a cargo yeah so it's a i i could
be wrong i mean
yeah i believe it's a four-cylinder car
so it gets really good gas mileage
the lease prices on those cars are
really affordable they're not bad and
they
look so good you could throw up a
picture of this and just
see if i'm right or not but i liked it
so actually the dealership gave me an
evoque
and i was like oh i don't like those and
i was like yeah it's a little squatty in
there yeah i didn't really like it but
then when i turned it back in i was like
what is that it was all shiny and new in
the in the lobby so
i took that home and i think my lease is
almost up so i don't know what to get
next
tesla tesla model x that's really what
i've uh
i've always said that that's what i
should buy you should i don't drive
though
like i think yeah the car drives exactly
i put 5000 miles on my car this past
year
that's a decent amount of the lockdown
and everything
that's a decent amount sure that i play
effect i like the model x because of the
uh
the doors that's really if get one if it
was just a little bit bigger
they look cool back to the future is my
favorite movie i've always wanted a
delorean so
if i bought a stupid car it would be a
uh delorean really yeah
andre jick wants a delorean really badly
really
yeah and it made sense like as soon as
he told me
the tricked out version with the yes he
does okay
yeah but as soon as he told me that he
wanted a delorean i'm like wait a second
that's a great car to get
i think part of me wanted a delorean but
i'm not going to
steal it really quickly yeah okay right
now but
funny would it be if we all three got
them and then drove them
just buy his house they've gone up in
value a lot lately those cars used to be
like
eighteen thousand twenty thousand
dollars a few years ago they're all now
selling for like 30 35 grand
do you think it's just all alternative
investments right now are just like
picking up
yeah if you're buying nfts of like
random things
then yeah there's a lot of alternative
investment going on everything like
watches pokemon cards like everything is
super hard
so odd why i don't know i mean
hobbies people are picking they have too
much time right now they're looking at
stuff we've had a lot of free time and
some free money
got dropped in their bank accounts and i
don't know
i've never really been a collector of
anything either so it's
pokemon's never really made sense to me
we had on dumb money that
thousand dollar fake pokemon oh we
should talk about the bible
so let me explain this so sebby sends me
this video
minutes after it happened so you need to
watch this immediately and react to it
and for for a long live stream like that
i'm like
let me at least scroll and like see what
i'm going to react to and just make sure
it's worth it
i started watching it and i couldn't
react to it because i watched the whole
thing
because i i couldn't take my eyes off
the screen so you bought
at the time the most expensive first
edition
box of unopened pokemon cards ever ever
it was right after logan paul bought a
300 000
box we were scrambling because we wanted
to open one we knew that the
market for these was going to accelerate
because they're now
famous and now people are going to want
these boxes and so we bought one
uh and had 2 000 or however 375 thousand
dollars yeah
um and the guy who actually was on logan
paul's
show hand delivered it to us he he
secured one
brought it to us we had uh leonhardt and
some pokemon
experts standing by ready to uh to look
at it
and uh then it comes time to open it
and it was a resealed box there were
fake
uh like they were real cards but they
were not the cards that were supposed to
be in there they were not first edition
cards
and it was just we we had no idea what
to even do
now we were not even expecting this live
stream to be a big thing at the time
live only like 2 000 people
simultaneously were watching it was
small because it's right it's a smaller
channel
yeah uh and then within within two days
there were
you know quarter million views on a
video that
basically it was a huge failure we had
people saying how poor the production
was yeah
you do a box break without having a
camera on the box yeah
i'm like dude i was i was buying
gear off of amazon the night before just
to be able to give you that much quality
wouldn't you think though that if you
were spending 375 000 on a box
you know like a few weeks ahead of time
to fly leonhard out there like
he was collectibles oh he's low okay
he's local all right
okay all happened so quick it literally
i had collectibles guru
uh in dms on twitter uh in one stream
and then
my amazon cart in in the other and it
was all happening within
a few days so what was your immediate
reaction when he opened up the box and
it was like all fake what was your
response it was it was just shock i
didn't even know what to do
like do we pull do we pull the thing off
the air
is this what do we do but it actually
just ended up being
the only thing that was good about it i
mean nobody would have ever seen our
375 000 pokemon box had it not been fake
so
i mean we had people saying uh you you
staged this whole thing
i can tell you this was not at all
staged and
it was it was shocking and i i didn't
even
i it was like i was in my own world
right
i'm also monitoring audio and people's
mics are going out and so it was
the whole thing was a disaster so you
were in shock you weren't feeling like
angry or you weren't feeling sad or
no no i mean it wasn't my money first of
all so that made it uh completely
like oh well right sucks to be chris
right now but
no we hadn't actually transacted the
money so it wasn't like we were going to
be at a
you know boss on this i'm i was actually
glad that we didn't
you know wait and not open it because
yeah it would be more dramatic
to uh do a box break for whatever the
you know
event charity thing is eventually and
have it just be already a perfectly
sealed box
i'm so glad that we actually opened it
because that would have been a huge
disaster
now you didn't pay for it right ahead of
time like you had the cash
but a suitcase full of cash because
that's how you either
you either buy it using bitcoin or cash
and so we we
it's a wire transfer not workers
apparently
they don't do that in this crazy pokemon
are you serious it's either cash or big
i think it was all we actually did end
up giving him the suitcase of cash
like uh that day a week later after he
sourced you guys what do you
do with that much cash though that's a
pain to deal with that much cash
uh even getting that much cash was a
huge pound how do you do that
you they basically give you a clear
garbage bag and you're just walking
through the parking lot with 375 000
in cash before you can put it in your
little suitcase
i'll i have some uh b-roll clips that
you can i would love to
insert into this now to get the cash you
didn't have to go in like an airplane or
take the cash anywhere you just you just
no no a local local bank uh they
had security there but it was not like
an armed guard or anything it was just
like
a dude who worked at the bank who said
oh yeah if you're parked right there
i'll keep an eye on you
wow did they question what this is for
i don't really recall they must not
believe
yeah i'm just like i was just so
nonchalant
well i think we in advance like told
them you know because
i don't know that they always have that
much cash just sitting in the vault so
i'm sure that there was like an order in
advance so they knew we were coming it
wasn't just like
hey i want to write a check for 400
thousand dollars and take it out in cash
what bank is it it was a wells fargo
nasty that's what i so it's it was
actually chris's money i
would never buy a 400 000 pokemon box
but
it was his money his bank i always give
him a hard time for wells fargo because
every time he needs to wire money he
physically goes into a branch why
because
he's an idiot jp morgan yeah i get free
wire transfers now chase
i use i don't know that's him now that's
nice
that's funny no i uh i use bank of
america and i can do it all on my phone
and
if you watch any of the original dumb
money channel you see like every time we
need to wire money
for some startup we're investing in
there's always like this scene of us
driving to the bank so chris can do it
while i'm doing it on my phone yeah he's
just
i had a terrible experience with bank of
america two terrible experiences the
first one was
i wired money from one account to
another
and i forget what it was but i i think i
switched
the routing and account number or there
was some sort of like a common error
that was there the wire was sent but it
was never received
and it was 150 grand oh try tracing that
back
and trying to reach somebody at bank of
america they have wire hours that close
down at like
5 p.m eastern time it takes like three
hours just to reach somebody who's in
who then is like
oh we gotta transfer you over to this
person and then it goes to a voicemail
imagine waiting on hold for like two
hours to go to a voicemail
it was terrible eventually the money was
reverted back i was so thankful but that
was
really just a scary experience i had
something similar happen
with e-trade back when i didn't really
know what i was doing and i got into
some
some kind of a position that i should
never have been in some
naked call position or something that
they ended up like margin calling me and
fed calling me on the same day and
just emptying my my entire account and
i'm like what
how how you can't do this where'd
everything go you you shouldn't have
even let me get into that trade i i
am not qualified to make that kind of
investment but
i can't remember it it worked out in the
end i finally got through to someone who
yeah understood but yeah so what's the
plan with the charity box break are we
going to be selling the packs
or how does this work i'm not sure
exactly the logistics of what we're
doing but basically
it'll be similar to other charity box
breaks
we'll be selling packs we'll we'll be
giving some to uh people in the dom
money community
we'll be giving some probably to some
creators giving some to creators
how do how do creators give and also
what constitutes a creator
[Laughter]
i think you probably both qualify i'll
um i'll definitely keep you in mind
yeah yeah let us know
okay okay now
would you do something like an nft
associated with that because i feel like
you could either do
like the raffle thing and you buy into
it and you raffle off
you would make a lot more money for
charity i feel like doing the raffle
the bidding system was interesting what
logan paul did
but those prices were just insane but he
had the nft attached to it
so what is your thoughts i don't know i
i would love to
figure out an nft that makes sense it's
just so hard to figure out something
that makes sense
i own a logan paul nft i have no idea if
it'll ever be worth anything
which what did you buy i bought one of
the original uh
three three thousand or two thousand
that he did for one ether each okay
i bought one of those in the aftermarket
when they had already depreciated
they depreciated that fast yeah what
about the uh the original box break one
that's the one that i have so he issued
that's where he made his five million
dollars
no no no no no no there there's box
break but then he had 44
unique ones 44 unique ones when you
received a pack you also got one that's
what i'm talking about i don't know what
those i i haven't
found those in the in the secondary
market so at all
i haven't seen them but i really shopped
i looked them up once and i saw the last
one sold for 38
500 which i was shocked
yeah i does any of it make sense
really do you want to have a uh graham
coin
maybe i think i think i think
there could be a lot of potential i
think for an nft kevin mentioned this in
one of his videos
uh and we mentioned it with uh blau on
the podcast last week
doing an nft that's valid for like let's
say one
phone call a month or like one
mentorship thing a month or something
like that
where they have access to me for an hour
and that could be resold in the future
basically a resellable subscription
correct the
person who bought it the first time can
change the price yes and then you would
get a
percentage if the transactions correct
happen
yes so but it would be backed by a
service yeah
uh in terms of the artwork i see there
being some value for certain pieces
right now it's a crap shoot i think
right now it's like throwing a shot in
the dark
is is people going to be a household
name or is he going to be the people is
one of those
beeple is because he was the first the
first to have these huge six million
dollar sales i think that
that kind of cemented him his place in
history and he will continue to have
value
i think that that is kind of like owning
a picasso right
um i think that a bunch of these other
random things are going to disappear i
also like uh
crypto punks because they were the
original original
yeah and uh so i gave away 14 crypto
daves for free
and i'm waiting to see if anyone sells
them right now someone's offering a
hundred dollars for one
there's no value oh this this was from
your video right yeah
so i just just just for fun i thought
yeah
just to see what the process is i want
to show how easy it is to actually
anyone can create one of these things
and what happens if i just give them
away
and does anyone want them yeah like
within an
hour people were claiming them wow um i
gave away one every hour for 12 hours
and like people were already offering
you know
they were free and then five minutes
later they were 50
and there's someone right now there's an
offer for like uh
170 or something so like there's no
value there's
you can't do anything it's a picture of
me pixelated with a stupid hat and
glasses
that's it i'm trying to get my dad to do
an nft so he used to work for disney
throughout the 1980s and 1990s as an
animator
and that's cool so he's done a lot of we
actually in this box over here we have a
lot of the original
animated artwork from like the little
mermaid and uh yeah and like beauty and
the beast
throw that in a nice climate controlled
environment
this has been sitting in a garage for
like 30 years
i'll show i'll show you some pieces
actually you know what um
you know what while we're on the topic
let me pull out one piece here
so much for staying on track with a nice
narrative dude we are just like
jumping from topic to topic i'm with it
though i i like it
yeah what who is who is this isn't that
101 dalmatians yes
yeah yeah so he was working on
this yeah 101 dalmatians how cool so
this is one of the original disney cells
i have no idea how much these are worth
i'm never going to sell them obviously
but he has his entire career basically
just
sitting in a garage right now and almost
none of it is framed but eventually i
want to get them all framed
but what was that this i want an
original though that's so
i don't want a token version but no
here's the thing i was telling him
because he's he's just always done art
um i think art in this sort of form
it's difficult to sell but if he could
create a digital version of his own
version of like
you know his own animations and sell an
nft version of that just a one-of-one
i think then it has and maybe i'm biased
because like i'm talking about my dad
here so obviously i'm gonna be like that
bad
but i think there's something to be said
about buying artwork
from real artists and that having value
at some point no absolutely
and i think a digital version of a
one-of-one from
an artist that you respect that you like
that definitely
value and i don't know exactly how
you're going to display it i guess all
frames in the future
will be digital and you can probably
pull up whatever you want but you could
pull up any art
really so the only the only thing is i
own this and i can prove it because i
have a copy of the blockchain right
so i agree i think it's kind of a
toss-up right now with evaluations of
nfts
i know someone who made their own nft
like digital artwork
they put it up online and sold it for
like 400.
and they have no following or anything
like background and digital like art or
like design or anything like they just
sold it for 400
and they're like oh that was my first
nft more to come wow
it doesn't make sense well it's so cool
though that people can do that i love
anything that just gives more access to
people to be able to sell whatever they
want to make something and be able to
sell it
like can you imagine like if i was if i
was able to
have youtube when i was a kid can you
imagine how like cool that would have
been yeah to like make videos when
you're like
i don't know how old you have to be to
be on youtube but like 16
when i was i was making mixtapes of me
being a dj if i could have like
sold those somehow back like and had an
audience that would have been super cool
yeah even only fans we got we gotta we
gotta respect the only fans here but
like there are creators making over a
million dollars a month
yeah on only fans it just goes to show i
don't know if right now does people have
so much money to spend
or if we're finding just new creative
ways
to make money it's a little of both
yeah jack how are you liking only fans
it's great actually
i'm kidding really a little community
[Laughter]
what do you do there i bet you would get
people that would sign up for you for an
only fans
you would too like maybe i'd get like
five i bet you'd get quite a few
what would i do on there like
what do you do
i don't know i don't know what is that
what is money teasing
i just made it up this is like shaking
money i don't know
that's an nft in the making yeah yeah
should i make an only fans i mean maybe
honestly i would
what if i could i produce your content
i'm leaving enough of it
what would we post i don't know what was
the money clips
with you and money i don't know
basically it's like i'm in a bathtub
just like full of hundred dollars
yes like that would people would love
that dude
but it would have to be like pg stuff
like i wouldn't be doing anything like
crazy like pg
maybe pg-13 i don't know yeah
we'll see well anyway
that's we really derailed your yeah we
just found our podcast yeah okay let's
go back to investing what's your
investing strategy now
what do you see in the market that
scares you a little bit
i'm basically the the last month
has scared me a little bit and i don't
know if i should be putting the brakes
on if i should be
you know hedging again if i should
just let it ride if i should be doubling
down if i
i don't know what to do so i really have
just kind of taken a step back and not
done anything
because long term that's probably the
right thing to do so
what about the market worries you in the
last month uh
the everyday being read was a big
problem
that that you know i don't know if it's
systemic we're going to actually see
this happen
you know for two months in a row
long term i think we're fine but we have
inflationary
worries we have you know there's just so
many things i'm not a macroeconomics guy
i just i just play stocks
i almost felt a little easy about the
market going down because when the
market was going up like a percent
every single day i was like how is this
possible but to see it just trace back
and some stocks go back like 20 30
percent
then it made me almost have some faith
in the markets like okay maybe people
aren't
that crazy maybe there is some some
logic to this
so that's not how i felt yeah and that's
great if that continues for
a month or you know a few weeks and then
we get some some up days
what i would just absolutely terrifies
me is if we had that happen for five
years
where you have stagnation or
you know just the market on on a
downward spiral not
not big drops not something that you
wake up one day and go oh well we had a
10
drop that that's the end and now it's
gonna go back up but if we have
you know two percent here up one down
two up one down two and that continues
for a long time
that is what scares me that's why you
selling covered calls
on your on your shares that's how you
make money in like a stagnant market
and that's what i've been doing to hedge
against like all of my equity holdings
during this like
last kind of like downturn or whatever
downfall whatever you want to call it do
things get
called away from you frequently when you
do that or you no no because
everything's been going down
so like nobody wants jack stocks
but fortunately like i've i've made a
little bit of my money back i'm still
way down
but i would be way more down had i not
sold these covered calls in my
my shares are you picking stocks that
have like a
higher uh call price like specifically
like uh like a higher premium um i
this is just in my robinhood account so
i have like a robin hood account which
is like my
you know fun money my risk higher risk
money that i have my td account which is
buy and hold
then i have vanguard which is index
funds my robinhood account it's all just
like yeah high premium stock like i have
a ton of palantir
i have apple which doesn't really have a
high premium but it's a little bit more
volatile
um i have neo stuff like that so yeah i
will you know on the calls that i sell i
can usually
get like 10 of the uh the share cost
uh with the premium yeah so the only
thing that will really actually hurt me
is if you know the stock plummets more
than 10
yeah or if the the share price just like
skyrockets and i'm you know
upside down on the option but i still
make it you get out money on the
appreciation and ten percent
premium as well yeah i i like doing that
it it just got
so time consuming to monitor it and keep
moving those call prices down and you
know
you want to do it for your shorter you
know weekly options instead of like the
longer term monthlies
and i usually just do monthlies because
it's like less to worry about yeah
so that's that's the i like about
simplifying it if it takes too much
mental power it's just like is it even
worth it oh i'm not gonna lie like
sometimes i i literally just going rob
and i click sell i click call i just
pick a random date and i like
pick like i'm not kidding like and it
works like especially considering what
recently
it works until it doesn't though no but
this is i mean this is hedging against
my
my my holding so it's not like the if
anything it's less volatile what i'm
doing but i swear like i literally
i don't even like compare premiums you
know if i can get like five percent in
one week versus 12
in two weeks like i don't it doesn't
matter to me i'm like i'll take anything
honestly that's why we buy stocks too
he just goes to the top movers section
on robin and he's like i just buy
that one yeah all right i'll buy it
i think it's my portfolio it's kind of
the same way though if you think about
i you know i have a lot of amazon and
tesla and apple and
those that is probably you know half of
my portfolio and three concentrated
three yeah high highly volatile stocks
wow i mean apple is right that apple's
my cash and then i i have a bunch of
things that i play with
right and so that's that just kind of
keeps it fun so what's your net worth
right now
i i haven't even even done that
calculation so my
fun brokerage account is around 10
million
uh my house is that's your fun brokerage
account
do you have a fun account for 10 jeez
i thought that was like everything
that's right all right
that's my primary that is that's the
majority okay um
but how is it the fun one though well
yes
it's the one to keep that's a lot of fun
10 million dollars you don't need that
much
yeah it was only four when i started so
it's been a lot of
that's why i call it fun because it's
and i'm gonna make i'm not gonna take
money out of that and put it into a
boring account i'm just gonna keep going
see a fun account um yeah and then i
have a
my real estate is very limited to my
house that i live in
uh which is i don't know three three and
a half did you
pay for that outright or do you have a
mortgage on that
at the time i had a construction loan
that uh
i you know it was a million dollar
construction loan that
i kept as a mortgage for about a year
and then i just decided to pay it off
hmm
why decide to pay off the home why
wouldn't you see that as a good way to
leverage your money
you get like three percent on that as a
cash out that's
true i for me it just felt like
i was more in control of all of my money
if i didn't have this
extra money that i was going to have to
pay back at some point right
just gave me more clarity and as far as
what i have what i can invest
i don't know it was it was kind of a
weird on
paper by math it probably doesn't make
sense but i just
thought this is the time just to get it
off
one less thing to think about right so
you have
10 million dollars in fund money 4
million in real estate
and then what else that's about it
what else is there so your fun money
they don't have i don't like
like a lake house i don't have any
exotic cars
just like a couple million here a couple
million there
really simple right okay that makes
sense like i i think
having to think about money too much is
just i i'd rather just not think i want
to get like that
it's it's it's it's overwhelming for me
to think of all the things like just
i got emailed today like with six
different like oh this this electric
account is getting billed today and like
making sure i switch that over to like
the new you know business account and
like
property tax like the accountant carol
she wanted all the property tax
statements i gotta get like eight
property tax statements
it's horrible making sure all that gets
paid and like the insur
the insurance i had to renew the
insurances and they have to call and get
the bank account information
i i envy just like one place you have
like a house
and a stock market account and i
basically stayed away from real estate
because it just seems like a hassle
like i get it that's a good investment
it's it's a totally
it's just something i haven't explored
and i just am not as comfortable with it
and so i just haven't done it i've been
telling jack about this
that uh i feel like when you really want
to build your wealth in the very
beginning real estate is such a great
way to do that if you have the time to
do that
yeah it's so hands-on it's possible to
get like a 50 to 100 return
on your money like somewhat safely in
the first year by like buying a place
under market fixing it up
now you have a whole bunch of equity you
could rent it out you get the cash flow
but as you start growing i feel like it
starts making
less and less sense just from like the
the time aspect of it
yeah i was actually looking at like a
eight unit apartment building
and that just seemed like it would make
sense because i could hire someone to do
most of
the work and i would just basically be
able to collect
you know paychecks that would or you
know collect rent that would pay the
mortgage for it
but it just even that seems messy
because you're always trying to make
sure that all the units are filled and
it's just why do that when you can just
sit back and watch the stock
the property manager that i have takes
care of like 90
of things but there's still that 10 that
i have to do
in addition to it and they were sending
me emails back and forth today at the
toilet
do you want to repair it or do you want
to just get a new one
it's a 100 difference between the two
i'm going to get a new one and then the
hvac that the ducting is like so some
issue with that that now needs to be
fixed
it's a hassle it's a hassle i don't want
to be dealing with it
it's enough to have to deal with five
air conditioning units in my main house
like there's always something that i'm
dealing with and i can't even imagine
doing that at multiple properties
that's why if i had multiple properties
they would be small
airbnb sized like one two-bedroom kind
of
condo apartment type things in places
that i want to visit
but even then airbnb so much easier yep
so do you not technically have an income
then like
how do you have capital to throw into
new investments
if a lot of your like worth is tied up
into like
long-term holds or something like that
um my
i use margin that's i go into margin
when i want to make a speculative
investment and pull out of margin and
get back to uh break even
or you know so most of just like the
the actual stuff that you own not using
margin
that is like all buy and hold and then
the margin is kind of just like
speculative
shorter shorter term trades i'll buy on
margin knowing that this is
this is i don't want to pay interest on
this money for the rest of time
but i'll buy you know when i was in
gamestop i didn't have extra cash
sitting on the sidelines so i
went into margin to buy some gamestop
and that was probably not the best idea
but uh yeah that's i i use i use my
brokerage account as my income
and just pull whenever i need some money
i pull some money out and i'm
checking i've been debating doing that
kevin has been telling me to do
that that's what he does he has no cash
in his accounts because it's all
invested and he just uses margin as like
a piggy bank
to go and pay for anything yeah i mean
it's a
you can negotiate your rate down it's
it's kind of worthwhile the only
difference between that and a mortgage
is you don't get that tax deduction off
of the mortgage interest which is
capped but you do get uh you your more
uh
your margin interest is deductible so
on your on your capital gains right
check with a cpa
yeah not an attorney what would you do
because i got the i got taxes coming up
and i got a big
tax bill i have the cash to pay the tax
bill
kevin what he's doing is he's uh
basically just
getting a larger margin loan against his
portfolio to pay his taxes
uh i'm debating it because it's like on
the one hand
it's just peace of mind like okay it's
done i don't know anything it is what it
is i'm back to square one again
or i could borrow it i think if you had
something that you wanted to invest in
you actually were like i need to have
this money to invest in this
i would do what he's doing he's fully
invested he's
fully on margin and when he needs money
to pay his tax bill he's going deeper
into margin
if you don't have that investment in
mind that you want to do i would totally
just
pay it because otherwise you're paying
more taxes you're paying
interest and you're not putting that
money to work for you in whatever
because you don't have an investment but
assuming i would invest it assuming you
would invest it
you just have to do the math are you
going to beat the margin rate
and uh any penalties on
delaying on paying your taxes are you
just going to pay it well i would be
paying it because that's also you right
you could just decide not to pay your
taxes and pay the penalty
no no i don't want to do that yeah
i i made that mistake last year by doing
the i didn't pay my estimated taxes
because i've always i know
same so stupid i just figured i'm just
going to pay a big lump sum at the end
of the year and that'll be fine
but it's just i mean in hindsight it
would have been better for me just to
pay the estimated
but i liked having more cash on hand
especially when the market was dropping
to be able to buy in even more yeah so i
now make my estimated payments and i do
it based on
a percentage of what the previous year
was which is such a weird system anyway
because
you don't know what your previous year
was because you're always filing i'm
sure you are filing an extension and
finally
the last i've never filed an extension
so
you probably don't invest in many
startup companies they
they're notoriously slow at getting k-1s
to you
and you can't file your taxes until you
have all your k1s and so i end up having
to push
push my taxes back and so i don't know
what i owe and so i'm now making
estimated taxes on what i think an
estimate of my estimated tax the whole
thing is wait a second okay so
i've already paid a hundred percent of
what i paid last year in taxes
so technically then i could file an
extension yes
and because i've already paid 100 of
last year i'd get i think it's 110
there's a safe harbor amount sure just
check and check on that but yeah you pay
a certain amount based on
what you paid last year and then you can
file an extension
and if you owe more this year than you
did last year you're not going to get
penalized
supposedly not not tax advice
changes everything i'm going to do that
talk to you yeah i mean that wouldn't
that doesn't increase
the risks of no okay
no i mean i've been audited one time
yeah oh that's a fun story what happened
um it was actually the uh the small
business department
sent an auditor to my house um because
apparently some 1099 miscellaneous for
like
a hundred dollars like for some random
little thing
uh they filed it twice and so i was
missing a hundred dollars
but they basically needed every bank
account statement every inflow
outflow you can imagine that my
finances are a little bit complicated
and this this poor woman
had to sit in my dining room for three
days
poor woman i had to sit in my dining
room handing her
every document she wanted for three days
and um
it ended up like there was just all
kinds of complications with things that
i had depreciated incorrectly and just
it was just a mess wow did it work out
in the end
i bet if they were to audit like anyone
who makes over a million dollars a year
there's going to be something going on
that they can just nitpick at
absolutely no way you can keep track a
lot of us yeah
a lot of it is open to interpretation so
then it's you
arguing your interpretation of the tax
code which is not exactly clear
you would you would think yeah actually
they the irs was pretty
nice about it yes they show up with a
giant binder anytime you have a question
and then they give you a copy of the
thing that they are basing what their
finding
was based on and then you have and i'll
a right to then
question that and take it to court if
you want i just settled and paid them
because again
i'd rather pay a little bit more than
have to deal with the mental anguish of
yeah so i've heard like both horror
stories
from audits but i've also heard that
anybody who's like complying with the
irs they're really polite
i've never heard a story be like hey
they're so rude to me you're missed
but it seems like i it if you if you're
working with them
they're nice it's just yeah
i've always tried to be as as like on
point as i can because i just
i don't want to have to go through it so
i've always just tried to like what do
you call it
cross your t's and dot your eyes and be
like precise and everything yeah
and you try but i mean you have an
auditor looking at your
everything you've ever done in the in
the year and then they then they opened
up the previous year it was just a
whole ordeal and they're going to find
things that they would have
classified differently and some things
they found that
were in my favor so it's like well we
found this it's going to cost you this
much more but we also found this that's
going to cost you this much less so they
kind of
so are they basically just going and
doing your taxes for you that's what i
asked her i said
if i didn't want to file my taxes would
you come audit me and just do this for
me
because you're clearly way more
qualified than me
because i don't know what i'm doing and
clearly the cpa i
had doing my taxes didn't know what they
were doing if you're finding these
discrepancies why did
why are we going through this process
how about you just tell me how much i
owe you and i'll just write you a check
right i mean that seems like it would be
a way easier system right
i agree with that that's always been an
issue with mine with the irs it's like
it's so weird how you have to come up
with how much you owe them
but of course there's always going to be
some error that you could possibly make
and then they're just going to go do
exactly what you just did but correctly
yeah
and they supposedly know how much you
owe why not just tell us
you you're doing the math to figure it
out like when you're auditing you know
oh this this one's off because we had
all these inputs and we are expecting
yeah it really shouldn't be
that hard i would love what do you think
of a flat tax
i would love it yeah yeah i would love
just
how about this how about we just call it
a flat 30
that's it everyone pays 30 if you if you
make a dollar or you make
100 million dollars thirty percent
it would simplify everything yeah same
for corporations and it wouldn't have to
be thirty percent
if you're taxing everyone at that rate
and there's no loopholes there's no
right if there's no deductions if
there's no ways for the
the uber rich to like do a fast one and
end up paying two percent
no everyone pays 30 percent on their
income for the year
but would it be net but you it couldn't
be gross but it's not going to be 30
it would end up being like 8 once you
once you factor in that you're
basing it on everyone's income
like the gross national product of
humans
and uh like so do you think like think
of corporate
so you think we would collect more tax
revenue doing like a 30
flat tax across the board to collect the
same amount
and each individual person would have a
way lower rate because you're also
doing it for individuals corporations
uber rich
i would love that if you do if you say
it like that though do you mean that
also eliminates like property tax sales
tax hotel tax like oh
no it goes to different places
like you still need to pay for your
local schools and hospitals with your
property tax
and you just i don't know what
california does with all the money they
take from you
but not anymore
i mean yeah how texas doesn't have that
and california does but we have bigger
property taxes it's just
you're gonna have to pay for roads and
bridges and hospitals and all of that
and i get it
pay your fair share make sense you're a
bigger house you pay more but
um i think there would be a way to
simplify everything
i would love that i think just a thirty
percent we could we could come up with
what it is here and then just
implement that we should love that yeah
i wonder where parking tickets go
because i've paid like 350 bucks in
parking tickets and that's like three
months
it goes for maintenance on the scanners
that they use to give you a parking
ticket
that's it i'm sure i'm sure it's not
even i don't think they make money from
parking tickets
it would be impossible money from
parking tickets i swear there's no way i
have paid so much money in parking
tickets in the past five months
the thing is they have street sweepers
that come through la
and i bet that those street sweepers
they actually make money on that
because they give off they give off
parking tickets if you park in the
street
and every single time i walk up and down
the street on like the weird thursday
first thursday of the month and
like that day they have
weirdest parking rules five to ten cars
every street have parking tickets and
each parking ticket is seventy three
dollars
it is okay well i can make they make
money i guess if the
if if the person driving let's say gets
120 a day
they're probably collecting a thousand
dollars worth of tickets maybe
that it's gonna be there's nothing on
the street the street sweeping machine
has to be maintained
the equipment the mailing the thing to
you the then court costs if you fight it
and the whole thing it it probably is
i would admit that they make a lot of
money i was trying to look into like the
financial statements of
of santa monica you should start a
youtube channel that
like that diet investigation i literally
was like trying to find the financial
states like where is all this income
coming from like what are their expenses
like because i was just wondering
what is their parking ticket income yeah
right and how much of a percentage
am i of their parking ticket i went down
that rabbit hole looking for where does
the toll road money go
and is it actually all being used to pay
for these roads that
when they first started making toll
roads back in the 60s or something
the whole premise was you're going to
have a
nickel toll to be able to build this
road and then we'll take away the toll
but they never did they just keep
raising the rate so what happens to that
money
i couldn't find it the santa monica
sales tax is terrible it's over ten
percent sales tax
ten percent yeah it's nuts las vegas i
think is 7.2
what was the best investment you've ever
made the best return
you've ever gotten and what is the worst
return the the most money you've lost
these are these are you have to give me
like time to research that i would say
probably tesla is the best return but i
still haven't sold it so i don't know
so what's your unrealized gain um like
two million dollars
but what percentage is that um
i don't know 200 percent okay something
like that ish
these are the questions that a lot of
the
i'm trying to check this thumbnail yeah
i think i got like 1300
it was like 1200 on tesla i i
could look it up yeah i don't know
that's pretty good
like a thousand percent on yeah
maybe 400 i have no idea somewhere
between 400 i still have some old
old microsoft stock that i don't even
remember buying that is probably like a
2 000 gain so that wow
but that's something that you know i
just bought a long time ago and
never really looked at it again and it
was never near the top of my account
because i you know i sort by
market value to see what i'm worried
about for the day and
there was nothing yeah that's the way to
do it just buy something and forget
about it
if do you think you'd be better off
today if you just held on to
everything you've ever bought or do you
think that you were better off selling
and
actively managing your portfolio that's
a good question i think actively
managing
because had i just bought
half those companies went out of
business like i found i found that old
login on yahoo that showed yeah this
company doesn't exist anymore i don't i
don't know what would happen to those
shares
um so yeah and i'm sure
i've made terrible trades but
in the end i've done better than having
just set
what's your investing style like are you
a value investor are you like a social
arbitrage investor
social arm oh you are oh yeah absolutely
that's very cool
that's kind of what i figured out from
scanning your videos
so it's what it's all and that to me is
like the one edge that you have over
an investment banker they don't know
what's
going on you know in the real world
where real people are shopping and
seeing trends before they make it onto
wall street so some of our
big trades um that we've talked about on
domani are things that are
like trends that we spot before they you
know caught wall street's attention
do you think those investment bankers
have like certain quotas that they have
to like check off their lists like
regarding net income like uh
debt-to-income ratio
long-term debts to like short-term
income stuff like that do they do you
think they have to do that
so they can't do social arbitrage or do
you think that they're just like
not in that whole scene i think social
arbitrage is probably
too hard to explain to the people whose
money they're
investing so that it would be hard for
them to run a fund that does
that kind of you know on a whim we've
decided to buy these kind of
shares because we we thought we had some
edge on
the market that would just be harder to
justify in your prospectus
and so it's way easier to say we
track the s p 500 we track the what's uh
portnoy's buzz thing we track the uh
social me mention frequency of what
people were talking
about 30 days ago so i mean they have a
system that's easier to explain in a
prospectus and
that's that's how that's the reason i
don't really invest
in those funds other than i love the s p
500 just as a this is where i'm going to
put cash that i don't
that that's my bank account it's the s p
500 really yeah that's my investment
i'm putting that in there being all
right this is money i'm locking away and
then i have a bank account
i can't imagine dumping money into the s
p and being like that's my bank account
do you know what i did with my uh all my
retirement accounts
i put them in triple leveraged s p 500
because i figure long term yeah i mean
that's a terrible
investment i would never tell anyone to
do that but that's what i did
because this is money that i am not
planning to ever need
if i if i need my retirement savings
something has gone wrong in my life
and if i ever hit that point i'll i'll
quickly re-uh re-structure what's going
on in those accounts
but to me it's that's like opportunity
money that
grows tax-free that if i want to be able
to blow it out
what better investment historically over
the course of
10 20 years what would do better than
the s p
the only thing i can think i would be a
triple lever why don't you just do that
throughout your entire portfolio just
100 triple leveraged s p
don't touch it i mean that is something
that i've given a lot of thought to
like would that beat me trying to
individually choose things like tesla i
wonder if it would
why wouldn't you just go and put a
million dollars in that and be like
that's my fund gonna leave it i'm not
gonna touch it
i had a half million dollars in that um
when the market started crashing and
that made me really nervous because a
triple leveraged bundle
would that go down triple inverse 16. 60
yeah and and the rule of percentages
once once it's gone down it takes twice
as much to go back up and so that's why
for a market crash situation being in a
triple leveraged is
you know it's it's death you can't you
can't recover from it yeah and so
that that was uh i was a little late to
pull the
rip cord on that and get out of it um
but it's it has since recovered too
yeah i remember i was looking at jason
oppenheim's portfolio and he was
invested
in triple leveraged oil etfs
and gosh i can't imagine how much money
that's gone up now
oh yeah i remember looking back at him
like i can't believe you're buying this
this is crazy he's like no we're fine
i'll do fine
oil's got to come back and sure enough
i mean he's right but i was thinking
like but no it's going to change the
whole like people aren't going to travel
as much but
he's right i mean we're at a time where
everything is just going up
yes we're going to hit a point where it
isn't like that anymore and i that's
when i think it's going to be like a
rude awakening for a lot of people who
are new to investing
where you can't just wait a week because
it'll get better
if i i don't see it happening anytime
soon but that's what i'm worried about
longer term like
when is that point when is that and
you're not going to notice it it's going
to sneak up on you yeah
so i was actually telling jack about
this he's never heard of
the lost decade yeah
so now charlie munger was talking about
over the next decade to expect
lower returns we're not going to see
what we have been over the next 10 years
which i agree with him
i could see a time where the s p 500
goes up
goes down goes up goes down and trades
within a range of i don't know
900 points and we're at the same point
10 years from now as we are today i
don't think that would be impossible
yeah i'd never heard of that um what
would you do in that situation
sell covered calls and you'd probably
yeah
you would make that's why you would
manage you would manage a sideways
market as
you know try to make money going down
and then appreciate going yeah it would
sell
puts ideally when it's at the lowest and
then sell code calls ideally once it's
not gonna be able to time it just
right but you know hopefully you would
be able to outperform
zero which is what it could possibly do
for 10 years so the goal would just be
with time decay utilizing that to slowly
just
make the premium money and hopefully my
stuff isn't called away from me and
hopefully i'm not forced to buy anything
by
by selling the put yeah that's why i
love options
i mean that would work and then you're
also buying the dips and you're buying
it over time so it's gonna average out
but
yeah what would you do
i don't know i hope to never see that
situation but i
i i feel like that would be so stressful
that i would just want to just like not
be in the stock market if it's just
going sideways
i'd be done you just pull everything out
if you wanted to and just
sit on your money
i might do that i don't know just the
the stress every day of having to worry
oh
it's a down day what's my strategy today
oh it's an up day
is that what you do now i no i try not
to
think about we we talk on dumb money
live uh
we we went weekly we went from doing one
a week to doing one a day
uh and that really had me probably
making more trades than i should have
and so i'm pulling back and we're only
doing three shows a week now
maybe two okay um just because
you can't make a good trade every day it
used to be
in our whole social arb thesis you find
one really good high conviction social
arb trade
a year and you might find two or three
medium convictions
a year you can't find one every week you
can't find one every day
and so it's it's like weeding through
the discord communities finding all
these amazing ideas and trying to weed
through and find ones that you
believe in that's that's kind of the
challenge now it's there's
so much information so many
opportunities so many ideas
that you can't invest in them all and
you don't want to invest in them all but
there's so many good ideas that you kind
of want to so it just comes down to like
having some discipline
and waiting for things that are truly
truly high conviction
and then having a little bit of fun with
small amounts in the things that are
medium and low conviction what about
bitcoin
i think you just started investing in
bitcoin didn't you um
i've had bitcoin uh i was buying bitcoin
at that all-time high back when was that
thanksgiving when everyone was 2017.
i was buying and then just watching
watching it go down i was buying bitcoin
i had um a binance account that had some
crazy weird coins in it i don't know i
basically now i'm all
bitcoin and ethereum a 60 40 split i
love bitcoin
it's going to 100 000 i should probably
move more money
over into it i just can't
mentally put my money in into it
i i don't know sure i've been doing so
far about
five grand a week into bitcoin uh when
it dropped the other week i think i may
have done like 7 500
but just to balance everything out
because i said i believe in it long term
i do too
yeah and so i feel like i have not had
the discipline of
taking money out of the stock market and
putting it into bitcoin but i should
it's so easy just i use coinbase and
it's so
simple to just transfer money it shows
up instantly i think you gotta wait like
two three days for it to withdraw the
money
it's so easy it just shows up like
instantaneously you buy it instantly
it's so much easier than stocks to have
to do that the feast sucks
i'm sure there's a cheaper way of doing
it but it is what it is it is easy
and i like that it's open on the
weekends and afterwards like
right now if you want to go and buy it i
i
think the stock market should be open 24
7. it it should
i don't know why there's no reason no
other than old-timey
stock brokers didn't want to work
yeah but it 24-7 be but it should be it
should always be going up and down
a market open somewhere yes around the
world why not have our stocks also be
available at all times
i would love that's a good question i i
don't know it could be just too
stressful
for people like i'm serious though
imagine having like millions in the
market
like doing some like you know more
gambling type investments i guess
okay yeah it does give you the
opportunity to sleep you know that's
true i didn't think of that if just like
after
you know 1 pm here all right nothing's
gonna happen till 6 30 in the morning
yeah but does bitcoin keep you up at
night like no a bit but
it's not that bad right like
no not no i mean if it dropped 50 i mean
it just it is what it is
what is your percentage of your net
worth allocated to bitcoin two percent
two percent i need to get to two percent
that's my goal yeah i'm gonna do that
uh when you're watching this dave later
just go do that
the funny thing is i invested one uh
a little bit over one i think i had like
total investors like 1.3
that's that's grown to two in two months
i i could see at some point this ending
up at a million dollars a coin
at some point maybe like 50 years from
now maybe
it's it's i think it's either gonna be
worthless or like a million bucks
it's one or the other and that was my uh
investment thesis in gamestop yeah
either gonna be worthless or i'm going
to
quadruple my money so i'm i'm good with
being in bitcoin
for the long term yeah and i need to get
more into it how about this give us some
stock tips before we wrap
up tell jack what to invest in i don't
give stock tips i don't have
what are you buying that jack can copy
coinage terms or something like that
like what's a
a rule of thumb stuff like that stuff to
live by as an investor
yeah um i buy low
sell high i i don't have like any
it changes every day you just have to be
listening
looking finding opportunities looking
for things that you
that you think you know that wall street
doesn't know that's that's what it's all
about
and finding like a correlation to
it's uh cold in texas pipes are freezing
generators are going to be in demand
the electric power grid failed batteries
and tesla and things like that
um it's it's it's just making those kind
of connections when you
have something that you see that maybe
other people haven't yet
connected to a stock trade every time
there's a hurricane
the roofing companies go up that's now
predictable
but the first time there was a hurricane
and the roofing companies all went up
nobody had thought about that i respect
your investing philosophy you know
what you're good at and you stick to
what you know like
you don't have a big allocation in
bitcoin you paid off your house although
maybe it didn't make complete sense
maybe you should diversify a little bit
you know stocks and you continue to do
stocks and you continue to do well
so that's good it works how about this
what stocks do you like
i mean i'll tell you my biggest holdings
for me
and my risk tolerance it's tesla and
amazon and apple those are my
but are you buying more of tesla um i
wish i had the conviction to keep buying
tesla every time it goes down because
you see that every time it goes down it
does come back up but i just
to for me to buy because i don't have
any other income it means i have to sell
something else and i really like
everything that i'm in right now
can you margin i could go deeper into
margin
i'm i'm i'm kind of at that threshold of
there's so many good things that i want
to be invested in right now that i'm i'm
at the point where
i've margined about as much as i'm
comfortable with i'm at like maybe 20
30 margin right now and i don't like to
go that much deeper
probably i'm a little too conservative
for
what i for the returns that i would like
but it's it's all
a balancing act got it i don't want to
be that guy but
you could theoretically sell some puts
on tesla
if you wanted to pick a price that you
were comfortable to buy it at and if it
didn't hit that price you could get a
little bit of income
to then buy more tesla shares i i could
do that and i've done that and i
probably should have been doing that
when
instead of buying the dip i should have
been shorting the puts
on the dip i love the the income
thing i gotta try that at some point
any question you may have if i can't
answer i would i got to enable it on
schwab
i i do that online or it's it's easy
it's just like placing an order instead
of
buy to open you do sell to open it's
it's a drop down right interest i really
really want you to do options all right
you know what i'll pull up my computer
we'll we'll
i'll do one now okay yeah let's do it
well i mean technically it's you know
not during market hours right but
couldn't i just
you can do a market order tomorrow but i
don't know if that's something that you
can't well can't we just do it now to
opening the market open
i'm not a huge fan of like you could put
a limit order in it's very complicated
but i
i wouldn't do anything like aftermarket
or anything like that i would
realistically probably wait you can do a
limit or it's not like you're gonna lose
a ton of money but just to be
what are you talking about like selling
puts so if you sell it
so if you sell a put you select a price
and a date so say your your price that's
called a strike price
say your strike price for tesla what's
tesla right now
7 15 or something like that seven
i have no idea i don't really have any
tesla so i'm not or what no no sorry i
meant uh like uh doing the uh the
covered calls
you wanna do a cover call covered call
is when you have the stock
in your account and you're willing to
sell it for a certain price let's
try a certain date how do you do it on
schwab do you do this yes
which is under the strategy the options
under strategy where your stock etf
right now
you have to apply yeah yeah you have to
five to ten days for processing
you could do it on robinhood instantly
oh god
you're gonna fall in love with it i
promise you that graham
it's awesome it's like it opens up
all these doorways in investing it's
like you can hedge your positions with
options
you can leverage your positions with
options you can do so much more
with options that you can't do when just
buying common stock
so like if i wanted to sell this at
market right now it's 98.39
i could just hit sell and sell it for
98.39 or i can write a covered call
for 98 and then i would be selling at 98
but then i would also be getting
this 1.89 and so you're gonna get an
extra four thousand dollars
because you did this instead of just
hitting the sell button and then that's
someone say the stock goes up uh
to you know 99 someone's going to buy
that if they have the option to buy it
at 98.
if it goes down say it goes down to 97
they're not gonna buy it and now you
have four thousand dollars
that you just get to use to offset your
loss because you have the shares at that
and then you know
they depreciate your best case scenarios
it stays at 98 so you
don't lose anything you get to keep the
two dollars
and that's kind of just like that's the
best possible thing
if it goes up you're losing out on it
going above 98 but you're still getting
that extra two dollars and it's cool
because you don't have to pick 98
dollars you could pick
105 so that's out of the money that
means it's
above the you know selling a covered
call above the market value
so and obviously premiums would be lower
because the chances of it hitting that
are lower people are paying less to be
able to buy it at that price
yeah but but if you wanted to sell it at
105. yeah if you ever hit that
then you would only be getting and this
is not very volatile you'd only be
getting an extra
19 cents yeah you get 366 dollars
you have to pay commission to do this by
the way oh you do it's
all 13 they base it on the number of
contracts
but in this case you're only actually
losing money if
the stock goes above 105 dollars and
what 19 cents because you have 19 cents
per yes so if you if you wanted to sell
this at 105 if it ever hit 105 you could
get an extra 400
for placing the order this way but the
downside is if it went to 110 you'd be
like
i just gave up five dollars in exchange
for 19 cents
you can do it every single week until
this goes up to 105. but obviously if
it's a slow creep you could just keep
raising that up
106 107. wait and then continually just
make money hedging against your own
position of shares
i might and experiment with that yeah
build a robot that did that for
you it would make it worthwhile i
there's so there's some
options that the option chain is just
like has an imbalance
and you can find like call writer like
these secret underground chat rooms or
people they're like oh this one's really
out of whack
and that is where you can actually make
money if you have the time and
you know for an extra 500 you can spend
an hour doing that
i use i did that for fun for a while and
it was it just got to be too much
you know too much mental overhead to
deal with it depends on your strategy
but you should definitely if you if you
have like an extra hour per day to just
go dig and try to find those imbalances
in oh they're they're
paying too much for these premiums and
the uh
the stock this is this is a stock that
you can do what it's called like a buy
right where you buy the stock and write
the call in the same transaction and
you're guaranteed to make money unless
it goes
to a certain threshold but there's
enough premium built in so that you can
get out before it hits that threshold
there's so many strategies the thing is
it's so complicated but so easy it's a
whole spectrum it's a whole
dark web that you don't want to go on
it's great yeah
i love it i want to try doing a few and
we could do them together just maybe
like i'll pick three stocks i'll sell
them so out of the money
and uh just collect the premium just try
it a few times yeah
see that's one way to do it you're
probably not going to find it very worth
your time
the way that i love to do it is to pick
a stock that's super volatile
or say wall street bets is hyping up a
stock like palantir
or tesla or anything like that you know
what they're doing they're buying as
many calls as they can on that
that's driving up demand thus driving up
premiums so you can sell
you know covered calls on your shares
for these exorbitant premiums i mean you
could get like
20 in a month on some of these stocks
sometimes 20
that's that's unbelievable i don't
recommend it
i love it i recommend it but if you know
what you're doing or if you're very
conservative with it
i've told jack it's like what is it
picking up pennies in front of a
steamroller
that is exactly what it is
no it's so safe down like that yeah but
that's if you're writing naked call
options
that would be picking up pennies in
front of a steamer holder i think so i
don't know from my
very limited understanding of this
that's that's my
analogy that i've seen online fair
enough
all right well is there anything else
you want to throw in here um
no do we want to talk about the uh dumb
money thing yes
so how do we just
tell me go right in it yep so dumb money
the original channel
is about to hit a hundred thousand by
the time this is on we will have hit a
hundred thousand subscribers
and we've decided to basically give the
channel away
to the next generation of creators we
want to basically
turn it into like a platform for people
who don't have a
big audience and so we're gonna take
submissions and
basically hire three people put them
give give them
a show on the dumb money channel and
we're gonna not make content there we're
gonna keep doing dumb money live
and then make the new the old dumb money
channel
into something new how do you find these
people well we're basically uh kind of
auditioning so uh
anyone can can make a video tell us
about your show idea tell us
you know if you have some great idea or
if you if you've
already done a show or you're currently
you know on youtube
send us a link and we are going to uh
narrow it down
and pick three and give them a show how
are the three of them all gonna
coordinate
on one show it's not one show they each
get their own show
oh i see just so they each supposed to
wrap ups and yeah
think of it like uh you know nbc has a
bunch of shows on it and
or cnbc has like fast money and mad
money and
other kinds of money other kinds of
money would be a good name
so basically yeah it'll just be and and
there'll be a reoccurring show
they'll they'll do two episodes a week
and you know that'll fill up like a
whole
are you worried though that the audience
is like not gonna like one person but
maybe they kind of like another and like
the algorithm is all out of whack
i think the algorithm is all out of
whack on that channel anyway because we
basically stopped making videos a year
ago
wouldn't it be discouraging to somebody
who's like making better videos than the
other two
and then it's like well i just posted a
banger but then like these other two
knuckleheads
they they ruined my algorithm so that by
the time i post again like fewer people
are watching
it depends like if if youtube thinks
about what you're looking for
you know i the whole thing about the
algorithm is they're trying to find
what you want to watch right and if you
have a playlist that has
this type of video in one playlist and
another type of video in another
playlist
doesn't that like i don't know i feel
like kevin does live and recorded
right and he's i mean people love him so
yes that's why that works but i feel
like you don't
maybe get as penalized if you have
organized your content
i don't know i think you're you're the
expert buzzfeed cut
jubilee they all have that but they have
a structure but they have different
series like they have witnesses
i don't know it will essentially be
three different series
on a single channel and each one will be
its own title
and its own like they'll be i don't know
concrete did that they were they're a
great channel and they had
such good content but they were
originally doing ben mallet videos and
they were doing like other documentaries
and stuff
what ended up happening was that the ben
malo was so successful
and nobody cared about the other stuff
and it hurt the channel to have like a
really good ben mala video
and then you'd have a documentary that
in my opinion was an amazing documentary
it just wasn't that audience and the
audience that wanted ben
did not want the documentary and it was
discouraging i think
uh for them to create this content
because nobody wanted it they just
wanted more ben
well it's almost like if you think about
i come from the startup world
if you think about an incubator where
it's basically
putting money into a bunch of different
projects and if one of them takes off
that's great we want to launch the
career
of the next great youtuber it doesn't
have to continue to live on money but if
they can find an audience there
they can they can grow from there that's
fair so they can eventually go off and
do their own thing
whenever they want it's it's basically
we're trying to
we're trying to incentivize people to do
this because we have fun doing it and we
basically we're not good at making money
doing it we just did it because we loved
it but
um if we can have people who are like
really gung-ho about making these uh
making content on youtube and we can
give them the platform and we can give
them
you know production assistants and
editors and and
basically pay them a 60 000 a year
salary to be able to quit their job
if if that's like i wouldn't say anyone
should just
jump into youtube but if you've been
wanting to do it but you just haven't
been able to
because you know you just can't afford
to right this is this is that little
push
i feel like part of me it just just
feels like uh
if you're gonna do it on your own you
would and there are so many
weird learning curves that like if you
were to throw me
into a hundred thousand i would just
drown because you're throwing me in a
body of water that's just too deep for
me to swim but
starting out your own channel and like
growing that and figuring out like how
this works this doesn't work and
learning
by the time you hit a hundred thousand
then you're like you're all prepared
like you've been
through it well maybe we can help mentor
them along the way
maybe you could help mentor them i i
will help judge how's that
that would be great i'll help judge yeah
so we we basically have set up an
email address you can uh send a link to
a youtube video to get a show at
dummoney.tv i'll put it in the
description and uh
they that's how we're basically taking
submissions cool
link down below in the description so
cool anything else all right
thanks so much for coming on everybody
really yeah i mean we met right it was
really nice to meet you
and uh that was a great conversation i
loved it we're all over the map on this
one good luck editing
guys let us know what you think of like
this sort of style this is
one of the few videos where we didn't go
in with the structure and we just
figured well we're just going to let it
flow and have a conversation
i'm sure some people like it some people
don't but let us know what you think
if you think we should continue more of
just like the free flow conversations
happy to do that
if not we'll go back to a more
structured approach
it's fair i think it's fair call but
regardless you should smash
one of the buttons there's a thumb up or
a thumb down
just just a thumbs up button
as far as we're concerned that other
thumb button doesn't even exist
just register the fact that you heard us
say this by hitting the thumbs up
yes and then leave a comment telling us
what you think
yes yes sounds great also don't forget
to subscribe it's totally free to do and
you get a brand new video from us
every single sunday if you hit the
notification bell you could be the first
one to comment on the video and jack
responds to like
almost all of the comments especially in
the first like hour or two so make sure
you do that
thank you guys so much for watching we
have all of the links down below in the
description you can get two free stocks
too
uh worth up to one thousand eight
hundred and fifty dollars and uh that's
it
thank you anything else that's it cool
thanks so much see you guys we'll see
you next time
if i did slow down on the main channel i
would double down on the podcast
really really what about the second
channel uh there's only so much if you
could react to
the podcast i think is unique so we are
in the 45th
ever right i i have no idea
we we have no idea they are completely
unprepared for this yeah we've
mismatched a few episodes like we filmed
some way ahead of time that we're now
posting
so welcome to the 44th ever
episode of the iced coffee hour my name
is dave
if you want to say dave from dumb money
and so far the podcast is made
three seventy nine how's this that's
perfect yeah
all right go for it your name is graham
okay news